[Musique]
de quel continent est originaire la
pomme de terre de l'amérique du sud
ce tubercule aurait été cultivés pour la
première fois dans les andes
il y a près de dix mille ans mais ce qui
l'a propulsé au rang de quatrième
denrées alimentaires la plus importante
du monde aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on a
appelé les changes colombienne l'arrivée
de christophe colomb en amérique en 14
192 marque le début de l'une des
périodes les plus intenses des changes
de végétaux entre les continents les
conquistadors espagnols ramène des
pommes de terre mais aussi des tomates
du maïs des haricots et des courges en
europe de la ces plantes rayonneront à
travers le mans le pli en à peine trois
siècles la pomme de terre qui n'avait
pourtant jamais été cultivé ailleurs
qu'en amérique du sud deviendra un
pilier de l'alimentation en irlande
le pays est devenu si dépendants de ce
tubercule que dans les années 1840 le
mildiou de la pomme de terre entraînera
la grande famine irlandaise les changes
colombien qui ouvre l'amérique aux
autres continents permettra aussi
l'arrivée des oranges en californie des
bananes dans les antilles et du blé dans
les prairies mais au delà des végétaux
ce sont aussi des micro organismes
responsables de maladies infectieuses
des animaux et des humains parfois
contre leur gré qui participeront à
cette première mondialisation
[Musique]